[Musique]
imaginez imaginez que chaque fois que
vous l'acheter chez un marchand
ce dernier contribue financièrement pour
vous à l'achat d'une parcelle
nous sommes au bénin
imaginez que comme chef d'entreprise
vous l'ayez découvert le moyen idéal de
faire croître votre entreprise de
manière exponentielle
tout en travaillant moins
imaginez encore que on est découvert le
saint graal du marketing et de la vente
cet argument unis d'une valeur
inestimable pour le consommateur et qui
permettrait à toute entreprise de vendre
aisément vous savez toute entreprise
humaine pour prospérer doit mettre
l'argent au service des gens et non le
contraire
une entreprise est avant tout une
équation à deux inconnues
deux questions auxquelles il faut
absolument répondre comment je peux
aider les gens et comment je peux le
faire différemment et c'est cette
préoccupation constante du chef
d'entreprise pour ses semblables qui
fait des chefs un leader ou non globale
d'achat gratuit veut améliorer le
quotidien et apporter la prospérité aux
béninois et au bénin c'est un avantage
financier qui a été négocié avec des
marchands pour aider les béninois qui
qu'ils soient où qu'ils soient
il faut arrive pour le tigre à accroître
leur patrimoine
au moment où je vous parle chaque jour 3
nouvelles d'entreprises se joignent à
cette gigantesque aventure pour
justement aider les béninois dans leur
combat pour la prospérité
le nouvel achat gratuit c'est avant tout
la promesse pour l'ensemble des béninois
de devenir propriétaire d'acquérir des
parcelles gratuitement et cela sans
aucune discrimination sans aucune
distinction sans aucune condition
et nous sommes là pour parler d'idées
nous sommes là pour parler d'innovation
nouvel achat gratuit et une nouvelle
façon de faire les affaires au bénin
cette façon intelligente simple et
redoutablement efficace d'aider les gens
tout ceci dans un partenariat gagnant
gagnant
c'est possible ces faits étaient faits
ici au bénin
l'idée en elle-même est une révolution
dans l'esprit et la conception que nous
avons des affaires de ce que la parole
business et c'est là le premier aspect
de la magie des livres igloo valascia
gratuit et voilà le deuxième aspect dont
je vais vous parler un auteur américain
peter broker un des théoriciens du
maillage maître dans l'art du management
moderne celui que ses contemporains ont
surnommé le pape du management affirmé
il ya plusieurs années déjà que une
entreprise l'avait deux fonctions et
seulement 2 le marketing à l'innovation
et globale achats gratuit et pour son
promoteur
la façon la plus rentable la moins
coûteuse et une machine totalement
puissante pour communiquer et vendre
c'est la deuxième magie de global achats
gratuit
enfin et comme financier c'est l'aspect
de cette innovation défaite tibet qui
nous passionne le plus permettre aux
béninois je le répète qu'il soit sans
aucune condition d'acquérir des
parcelles gratuitement de devenir
propriétaire c'est et ce sera encore
pour plusieurs années
l'une des innovations les plus
importantes tous nos sens 12000
kilomètres carré de ciel aider les
individus à économiser et pas seulement
à dépenser les aider à mettre de
l'argent de côté pour accumuler un
patrimoine
ce n'est plus juste concept de finances
personnelles
c'est désormais une réalité offrir aux
entreprises un moyen infaillible de
faire croître leur entreprise de le
développer deux communautés de vendre
tout en dépensant moyens fournis sur
moins d'un moins d'efforts c'est une
révolution
nous avons conçu par dont nous avons
collé au bénin ce que j'appellerais le
règne de la fonction publique où tout le
monde ne jurait que par un poteau ou une
plante dans l'administration
depuis quelques années nous sommes à
l'ère des start up et de l'entreprise ou
le privé à juste titre est perçu comme
le moyen le plus sûr et le plus honnête
surtout de s'enrichir et de se faire une
place dans la société avec global achats
gratuit nous faisons un bon dans l'air
de l'investissement nouvel achat gratuit
n'est rien d'autre que l'expression de
la notion de revenus passifs
c'est la promesse pour le promoteur de
ces petits vélos pour les entreprises
partenaires et pour l'ensemble des
consommateurs béninois l'assurance
d'avoir un revenu régulier constant et
je dirais même croissant bref ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'une machine à faire de
l'argent
global achats gratuit pour finir c'est
accessoirement une invitation aux
consommateurs à jouer leur rôle dans
l'économie et aux entreprises une
excitation à améliorer la qualité du
service à la clientèle qui rame c'est
d'abord et avant tout cela l'innovation
c'est cette façon d'être toujours en
avant du mouvement global achats gratuit
aujourd'hui n'est même plus juste une
idée
c'est une révolution je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]